- I'm about to watch and
react to "Freaky Eaters".
Hate the name of the show,
but let's check out if there's
any nutritional value in it.
Bee-whoop!
- [Narrator] 20 year old
Amy is addicted to Cola.
She drinks on average
30 cans of Cola all day,
every single day.
- Wow!
30 cans.
What is it?
12 ounces per can.
30 times 12 is 360 ounces.
The two liter is 64 ounces.
That's basically five of those.
She drinks five two liters a day.
Holy moly.
First problem right off the bat,
tremendous amount of added sugars
in each one of these cans.
If I was to show you before
I pop up the image here,
how much actual sugar is added
to each one of these cans,
it will blow your mind.
Take a look.
- The most I had probably
in a day is 50 cans.
I'm always drinking Cola.
- Also not good for your teeth
and not good for a lot of body parts.
Also, what else is in Cola?
Caffeine.
That's a ton of caffeine,
especially if you're taking it at night.
There's no way you're
getting restful sleep
on that much caffeine.
- I do get tired a lot.
I don't have that much energy.
- 'Cause you're not sleeping well.
We said that right off the bat,
you're having too much
caffeine, too close to bedtime.
And then on top of it,
every time you drink this sugar,
a sugar basically,
every time you drink a
Cola, your sugar spikes,
your insulin spikes,
you get a little crash.
- [Narrator] Recently, Amy
had a serious health scare
when she discovered a lump in her chest,
which her doctor suggested
might be due to excess caffeine.
- I think that you drink too much caffeine
and that is why you have the tumor.
- Hold up.
None of that makes sense to me.
I think specifically with caffeine,
we've seen studies that show
both a protective effect
on breast cancer.
Small rare studies show that
there's no change in breast
density for premenopausal
women like herself.
So like I don't buy that
that tumor or mass was
caused by caffeine itself.
I've just never heard of a case like that.
Could have contributed due
to an unhealthy lifestyle.
Yes.
But due to, due to, no.
(dramatic music)
Wow, that's a lot of Cola.
(soft upbeat music)
That's a lot of sugar.
- Wow!
- 950 pounds of sugar is what you get
in your Cola each year.
- I don't think that's
understandable to the human mind.
But they love it for the dramatic effects
so they could stand in the
backyard and be like, "Wow."
- What we see right here is
you're already a pre-diabetic.
- Okay, if this is a fasting, blood sugar.
The glucose range puts her
in a pre-diabetic range
of being at 115.
Also I'm very, very surprised
that her triglycerides are so low.
Triglycerides is what you
would expect to be high
in a person who has uncontrolled
or poorly controlled sugar
or a high intake of sugar
because the body stores sugar
through triglycerides in the blood.
But the pre-diabetic
things should scare her
because while pre-diabetes
doesn't mean diabetes,
it is curable at that stage.
Once you become a diabetic,
you're diabetic for life.
Your risk factors change.
- [Narrator] 24 year old
Michael lives on meat.
He averages up to 150 pounds monthly,
that's equivalent to an
astounding 1800 pounds a year.
- The real problem with overeating
meat is your overexposure
to saturated fats.
If you're eating a hot dog,
you're also consuming a lot of carbs.
Not only are you overeating carbohydrates
that have been bleached,
therefore rapidly converted to glucose
and then rapidly stored as
fat if you don't eat it,
you're also consuming saturated fats.
So all of that ends up raising
your bad cholesterol numbers,
your triglycerides puts
you at increased risk
for heart disease, stroke.
Anything with cardiovascular conditions.
- [Narrator] In one day,
Michael can put away as much
as five quarter pound hot dogs,
a rack of ribs, two steaks,
and up to 30 chickens wings.
- Red meat is a maybe carcinogen.
Like it's still not all the way there.
It's like suspected.
But the ones that are suspected
are the processed meats,
like the hot dogs, like the chicken wings.
So you wanna avoid those and eat those,
like almost get rid of them totally.
But occasionally if you're
going to a football game
and you have a wing,
to me I think that's a reasonable balance.
- I'm a licensed psychotherapist,
specializing in eating disorders
and addictive behaviors.
- J.J. Virgin.
I'm a certified nutrition specialist
and a certified health
and fitness specialist.
This is a ridiculous
amount of chicken wings.
- I don't like the
confrontational nature right away.
You can't come in to
a healthcare encounter
with that kind of attitude
and hope for good outcomes.
You're setting up the
encounter for failure,
right from the start,
when you come and judgmental like that.
- So this would be dinner.
Two and a half pounds of meat right here.
- Two and a half pounds
of meat is a lot of meat.
When we're talking
about a portion of meat,
it should be around six ounces
really, like a fist amount.
- Oh!
(dramatic music)
- That is one month worth
of your meat consumption.
- Where is this?
Where is this being filmed
that they just jammed all
of this meat in there?
Outside of being a cool visual for TV,
I don't know how this
helps change his mind.
Like if I'm him, I see
it and go, "Okay, and?"
- It looks good.
- You think this looks good?
- Yeah, that's what I was gonna say.
Like, how do they think
this would turn him off?
- We see this AA/EPA ratio,
which tells you the risk of heart disease.
- What is this that they're looking at?
This is an anti-gladin
immunology blood test
that tells you whether or not
you have antibodies to gluten.
(error message sound)
What is this tell him
about his meat consumption?
These are not the lab
tests that I would show.
The test I would show him is his LDL,
his triglycerides are gonna be quite high.
Having really elevated triglycerides
puts you at a risk for pancreatitis,
which can be a life-threatening condition
requiring an ICU stay.
- You're 24 with high
risk of heart disease.
- Yeah.
What she was saying and
what they were showing
all make no sense.
Her actual statement is fine.
He is at higher risk,
but not for the reasons
that they just showed.
- [Narrator] Victor lives on cheeseburgers
and cheeseburgers alone.
- No, no.
- I love the burgers.
- [Narrator] He eats four burgers a day,
28 each week, which is nearly 1500 burgers
every single year.
- It's meant to be fast
food to be on the go
every now and then
not to be something that
is your primary meal.
And if you develop type 2 diabetes,
because of the diet that you're following,
one that is high in fat, high in sugar,
what ends up happening is
you have high risk of stroke
and heart attack.
Yes.
But also high risk of
developing problems in your eyes
leading to blindness.
Peripheral neuropathy,
where you feel pins and needles,
or even lose sensation
in your fingers and toes.
And that becomes such a problem
that you might have a rock in your shoe
that you don't even feel
and then it leads to a terrible infection
that leads to an amputation.
Like think about the cascade
of events that were to happen
just from overeating
burgers your whole life.
(cartons rumbling)
Again, with the cool visuals.
I could see them in the producers room
"Let's get cartons of burgers
to show the truck and open up.
Ah!"
(beep)
(soft piano music)
- [Narrator] 29 year old
Eric of Cincinnati, Ohio
is addicted to French fries.
- [Eric] I eat basically
just French fries.
- You can't grow up to
be a functioning adult
just eating potatoes and French fries.
Like you need vitamin D.
Rickets is a legitimate concern
for people who don't eat or
consume enough vitamin D.
Calcium.
- [Eric] I'm very active.
I skateboard once a week, if not twice.
- [Narrator] Because of
his athletic lifestyle,
Eric hasn't become overweight
and doesn't think French
fries are damaging his health.
- The way you look and the way
that your body is functioning
is not the same thing.
My cholesterol video that I made
talking about my blood test results,
I was losing weight 'cause I wasn't eating
a lot of calories.
But the quality of the
foods that I was consuming
was leading for my
cholesterol to creep up,
go real high and therefore
put me at a higher risk
for having a stroke or heart attack.
I may have looked great.
My abs may have been coming in,
but that didn't mean I was healthy.
Weight is an important
factor of someone's health,
but it's not the sole determinant
of someone's health status.
- Eric needs a dose of shock therapy
to really come-
- Oh yeah, that's what he needs.
Shock therapy.
- French fries,
starch, salt, fat.
This is the worst type of fat
that you can possibly eat.
It's trans fat.
- Yeah, trans fat is a big problem.
And in some countries
and parts of actually
the United States have outlawed
or reduced the amount of trans
fats that can be in foods.
Initially trans fat was added
to our foods in the 90s,
but then we realized that it
truly does spike your LDL,
your bad cholesterol and lower your HDL,
your good cholesterol.
So it's like a doubly negative
effect on your health.
And we saw rates of heart disease
just absolutely skyrocket.
Now that being said very
important point here,
just because something
says no trans fat on it
doesn't mean it's a healthy meal.
(rock music)
- We wanted to show him
the amount of French-
- Please show him, show him the fries.
Get the burgers or the fries.
Fork lift, truck.
(beep)
- This is LDL cholesterol.
It's the worst kind
and that's what this elevated
number is right here.
- LDL being 110 is
slightly elevated for him.
So it's not even that high.
But a 110 is not nearly
something that is scary.
Very surprised.
These blood work results
are very suspicious to me
that he doesn't just eat French fries
or he's a very unique anomaly.
(rock music)
- [Narrator] Daniel has
been obsessed with raw meat
for the past six years.
He feeds his habit four times a week
in pound after pound of raw beef,
eating full steaks pulled
right from the packaging.
- If you look at cultures
like the Iñupiat,
they were quite healthy and
they eat primarily raw meats.
They didn't even eat that many vegetables
'cause they didn't have it.
They lived in the Arctic and the Tundra.
But what they did eat
was the entire animals.
So they got fiber from
the parts of the animals
that we no longer eat.
So there's a lot of problems
when people try and look at
what other cultures do
without fully understanding
exactly what they do and how they do it.
- [Narrator] Even raw chicken.
- Can somebody say salmonella.
- I have never gotten sick
from meeting raw meat, ever.
And I've been doing it for six years now.
- It just takes one
time to get really sick,
to get ICU hospitalized,
to potentially get a colitis so bad
that you need a colon resection
and then need to wear a colostomy bag
to realize that,
"Wow, I probably shouldn't
have been doing that."
I'm as a doctor, can't tell
this person what to do,
nor should I tell this person what to do,
nor should I judge what
this person is doing.
But what I can do is tell them the risks
of what I just said,
and then see like, are those
risks acceptable to you?
And if so, why?
And if the person is cognizant
and they can understand and
accept those risks, that's it.
- [J.J. Virgin] You do have a parasite.
- So this looks like they gave him an ova
and parasite test of his stool sample
and they saw that there's a parasite.
But they didn't do a taxonomy.
So they don't know what
kind of parasite it is.
And it very clearly states there
that there's no treatment
that's even necessary
if the patient doesn't have symptoms
or other inflammatory markers.
That's an important note there.
Something else I wanna point out
is if you eat under
cooked meats quite often,
you put yourself at a risk
of developing a tapeworm.
Undercooked pork can lead
to a cyst forming parasite
that can actually lay cysts in your brain.
You're risking all these
things for no real benefit.
Like just cook your meat, somewhat.
- One more thing that's
of interest on this test,
rotting protein that hasn't
digested sitting in your gut.
(error message sound)
- They need to stop ordering these tests
that mean absolutely nothing.
Like this show is so ridiculous.
My God.
I've actually went vegan and keto before.
Click here to check out those videos
and learn about those diets
and as always stay happy and healthy.
Which one you clicking on?
(upbeat music)